toutes les semaines aussi dans cette
émission avec toi on va appeler un pote
à toi on va lui faire ce qu'on appelle
le corbeau tu m'as donné beaucoup
d'infos sur un pote à toi qui s'appelle
moussa j'adore moussa en plus cerné son
père monsieur raser son adorable et gens
adorent ça rate ses deux res ça m'a
donné plein d'infos sur limoux ça ça
rappeur un acteur qui doit jouer dans la
série validé qui va arriver sur canal+
qui est également vice colère en ce
moment exactement qui cartonne et c'est
vrai que c'est un des acteurs fétiches
tu l'aimé beaucoup et on va essayer de
chauffer un peu puisque tu m'as donné
des infos sur lui c'est le corbeau qui
va l'appeler donc je m'en charger est ce
que l écart mais je vais de suite happé
mots ça sent bon la vologne
alors oui môssieur who salue cet art
dont damas hama momo s'accroît alors tu
t'endors est-ce que je rêvais dix mois a
pas perdu ton portefeuille qu'il a
failli marquer à tapas du temps partagé
ah ouais
il y avait atteint la vie tout avec un
bilan qui sera riche et vibrante avec un
supporter qui a du coup apporté par tous
les menteurs je vois toutes et tous les
jeunes guerriers tombés à millas et tu
sur la scène bell c'est brahim ben ali
fait le ferait un parfait tu t'es rien
en fait le corbeau coutume artois
corbeau c'est du bon pied et aider mais
qu'est ce qui t'a titanesque aux accords
bâtiments mal j'aime pas les grossesses
aucun train castor billet vert tend plus
grosses fesses combien de femmes plus
parce que prévu oui c'était niet sabrina
c'est chaud je tends à penser à tarnos
et la garder l'anonymat s'est il
réellement
moutarde
moussa c'est cyril hanouna savamment
moussa avant j'aurais trop gastambide
hauts plateaux voulait faire un gros
bisou et hautaine fort la famille à
l'ubo saloum
[Applaudissements]